the just department filed an anti-trust
lawsuit against google today finally
they allege the use of anti-competitive
tactics to preserve
their monopoly in search and advertising
senator josh hawley has been one of the
very few leaders in the republican party
who has stood strong
against the abuses of big tech will this
suit do anything
to stop the censorship and the creeping
power
of people who are already too powerful
senator hawley joins us tonight senator
thanks so much
for coming on well how do you assess
this anti-trust suit
it's a very big anti-trust suit tucker
this is the biggest anti-trust case in a
generation maybe in a century
and i have to say reading that case this
morning reading the case title united
states versus google
i mean it just made me want to say god
bless america that's got to be the most
patriotic words that have been
written down in a long time united
states versus google i hope we'll see
united states versus facebook
really soon too but what's at stake here
is our democracy and who controls it is
it going to be citizens is going to be
voters
or is it going to be big tech and as
we've seen in the last few days
tech wants to run the elections they
want to run this democracy they're
trying to buy joe biden with all of the
money that they've spent on the biden
campaign
this is about standing up to them and
saying you cannot run america
that is exactly right now we've got
two weeks before the election you know
hoping that one party doesn't control
the whole government that would be a
disaster but it's possible that could
happen it's very possible the senate
could go to democrats
so in that two weeks to republican
senators who are the last hope i would
think to stand up against these
monopolies
plan to do anything to curtail the power
of these
companies yeah well it's absolutely
vital that the senate stand up and do
something and the republicans lead the
way
and what needs to happen is we need to
subpoena jack dorsey we need to subpoena
mark zuckerberg
we need to bring them in front of the
judiciary committee and say what are you
doing
what are you colluding with the biden
campaign why are you suppressing
the reporting of the new york post why
are you trying to interfere in an
election
we also tucker need to pass legislation
right now
that would change that section 230 that
immunity shield
allow americans to sue if you get
censored
you should be able to sue we should hold
big tech accountable i got to tell you
republicans have drugged their feet on
this
for two for years years and years and
years establishment republicans have
looked the other way
that's how tech has gotten powerful now
it's time to stand up and be counted
it's it's it's beyond belief do you
think that will change
i mean you work among people who are
taking the side i hate to say this of
google over their own voters
at what point will they wake up and
realize that's wrong
when voters tell them that it is i mean
when voters make clears they are trying
to do tucker i mean voters are trying to
get
politicians attention in every way they
know how the politicians just won't
listen
that's what i found i mean tech has
bought so much
influence on capitol hill so much
influence with think tanks and
economists and staffers
it is unbelievable and the voice of the
people is going to have to prevail
over these paid sycophants but that's
the fight right now and republicans
they've got to stand up now again they
have been complicit many of them and
allowing this situation to get to where
it is it's time now to stand up and take
some action
amen they're all so afraid or they've
been paid for i appreciate your coming
on tonight senator josh hawley of
missouri thanks so much